hey guys it's been a while since I took
the time to talk with you directly so I
wanted to just kind of pause everything
else and let you guys know that I'm so
sincerely grateful for everything that
you've done and not just for me you know
done for this community that we're
building for the world that we're
changing because if you're new to my
channel and you don't know every single
month we've done a charity livestream
and so far we've managed to raise
forty-eight thousand dollars for various
charities and we're gonna raise twenty
thousand dollars this weekend
I guess I'm announcing that right now
there's going to be a charity livestream
this weekend on Saturday starting at
10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time over on
the twitch channel so um I'll let you
guys know what charity we're raising for
but that's kind of an aside here because
I just wanted to really let you guys
know that I'm actually really proud of
what you guys have done and I said this
in the mail video but it kind of got
lost towards the end when I was
responding to a letter that someone gave
to me but I was really thinking about it
and I'm I'm truly and sincerely proud of
what we've managed to do here I mean all
joking aside you guys have managed to
help me out in more ways than I've ever
known in my life I mean you really took
a liking to my draw my life video and
and I never thought I'd get that big of
a response to it
but you know and you guys have really
taken to heart my cause of trying to
raise money for charity and I'm just
proud of what you guys have done because
it's not me that doesn't you know at the
end of the day I just organize it so
that you guys have an opportunity to do
something more and what you've done is
go above and beyond every single
expectation that I've ever had you know
I don't even have to ask anymore for you
guys to donate I really don't because
you so readily do it and I'm so happy
that you do because what we do here is
something that no one else really does
you know not many I mean some do but not
enough you know we're starting something
here that other people are finally
starting to take notice of I mean the
channel itself is all well and good
because a channel if you've been keeping
track has been growing unbelievably
quickly I can't even keep up with it
anymore we're literally one of the
fastest growing channels
round with over 3,000 subscribers a day
for our size I'm not talking the biggest
ever but we're rapidly approaching the
one of the biggest channels ever and and
I'm so grateful and I think it's because
that you guys have created such a unique
and interesting and welcoming
environment and environment that
enchants the cause of raising money for
charity and and that's really what I'm
all about and that's really why I'm so
happy that I get to do this every day
because you guys have done amazing
things that I never dreamed could be
possible and that's why I'm proud I'm
proud of you guys and you guys should
definitely be proud of yourselves
and I mean there's you know obviously
some trolling in the comment sections
and there's some negative people around
but you know in the end they don't
matter because the comments and things
are just talk and in the end talk
doesn't matter it's about what people do
and you guys have done amazing things
like I can't even begin to wrap my head
around how this is even possible but
it's been done and you guys are
exceeding it every day I mean my goal
was to hit a million subscribers by
March of next year but if you've been
keeping track you'll notice that we're
on pace to hit a million in November
towards the end of November sometime and
in all probability we'll hit it before
that because as time goes on the
projection kind of gets pushed back if
we kept it the same rate we did now we
did it in November and then we're
probably gonna go up from there so ah
but in the end that doesn't matter to me
the numbers of subscribers said I have
doesn't matter to me
the amount of money that we've donated
charity that matters to me because my
goal at the end of this year was had
$50,000 and this weekend we're gonna
blow that goal out of
you know as a personal thing to meet
with my dad having cancer and you know
all the people in my life that have been
affected by various diseases one of my
best friends you know we raise money for
him you met him he was Tyler shied for
the Yunus charity driving and you know
so many people around us are affected by
these diseases that are gonna be
preventable in a few years if you guys
keep it up
you know we've spreading more than just
goodwill across the world we're
spreading a kind of hope that this like
what we do here playing games and going
together and just enjoying videos on the
Internet it can do more so long as we
all take the extra step to do more so
sincerely thank you guys for everything
that you've done and everything that
you're going to do and and I know that
going into the future you're gonna beat
my expectations and you're gonna beat
them into the ground and the more people
we get em and I'm grateful for the new
people that are here to if you haven't
gotten a chance to donate yet because I
know we got about a hundred thousand
subscribers more since the last charity
livestream so I know there's a lot of
people that don't know about it but
please join us this Saturday for another
charity livestream I'll pick out the
charity later on um we're thinking
testicular can't are not texted prostate
cancer which is kind of the male
counterpart to breast cancer it affects
about the same number of men that it
does women of breast cancer so it's
pretty big thing on the on the flip flop
of that one but anyway please join us
for this Saturday starting at 10 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time figure that out
for your timezone and please give
generously because we're doing a world
of difference and I'm just grateful that
we can do it so sincerely thank you guys
for everything you've done all silliness
of mine and all screaming us and all all
just acting out of the box for me is is
all well and good I'm glad you like it
but what's more important to me is what
we do and what you guys have done from
so thank you so much I mean we're gonna
be breaking milestones left and right I
mean four hundred thousand subscribers
are coming up in a few days here we're
gonna hit that and that's all well and
good more people into the fold
and I guess that's great but in all
honesty the one thing that matters above
all else is what we're building here and
what we're able to do when we've all
gathered together and put our minds to
it so thank you guys sincerely and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye